(dramatic music)
- [Voiceover] Previously
on The Roomate.
- Quinta makes me feel like a desired man.
I feel a real connection.
Everything just feels right.
- Seeing Justin with
another potential roommate
makes me question everything we have.
He told be off camera that I was the one,
but then he confessed to
me that he ordered takeout
at my favorite place with Quinta.
Hey there.
You mind if I steal him away?
I just don't trust her, OK?
There's just something about her.
She's just not being faithful.
- [Justin] What?
- [Zach] That's all I'm gonna say.
- Honestly, I just need to
know if he's gonna live with
me or Zach.
I don't really care,
I just need to know.
- At this point I just
don't know, I (sniffles).
- Justin, do you like the
way the bathroom smells
after he as Chick-fil-A?
- I would prefer if you burn some sage.
I just want someone I can trust.
Pay the rent on time every month.
- Let the games begin.
- [Voiceover] The drama continues
on The Roommate.
- [Justin] Today
I will make the hardest
decision of my life,
to live with my girlfriend Quinta,
or my best friend Zack.
These past weeks I've felt
a really special connection with Justin,
and I think he did too, but
if he chooses Quinta
I don't think I could
ever talk to him again.
- I've gotta look at
another apartment in like
20 minutes,
so I just hope this doesn't make me late.
I honestly don't know
why I agreed to this.
- OK, guys, I have the final key here, and
I'll need you to pick one of
these final two contestants
to sign that lease with you.
So.
- [Justin] Thank you.
- Just.
- These past 29 weeks have been
magical.
Zach, we've had some
amazing times together.
We've beaten every level of Call of Duty,
and we binged all of Entourage.
I seriously view you as my Turtle.
- And you're my Johnny Drama.
- And Quinta.
You're my dream come true.
You like my cats, if you lived here
I could see us throwing
some pretty sick ragers.
I could definitely see myself spending
the rest of my lease with you.
However, there can only be one.
(melodramatic music)
- Quinta can I talk to you?
(dramatic music)
- What's going on?
- I know you watched Game
of Thrones without Justin.
- Oh my God, so what,
Zach? It doesn't matter.
- You broke a sacred creed with him.
- I don't know,
I just know that, you know,
we need to get someone
on that lease today, so--
- I know. OK.
- Just.
Make that decision, get that
security deposit in, and--
- Sure.
- You're lying to his face.
- Would you stop? It is
not that important, OK?
Just chill.
So I did watch a few
episodes of Game of Thrones
without Justin, I don't get it,
why is Zach acting like this?
Oh my God, ya'll are so annoying.
- I'm acting like this because
Quinta is a lying cheat.
She's gonna have to
tell Justin before I do.
- You OK?
- Yea.
I'm just a little shaken.
Guys, what,
what happened? What's going on?
- Quinta
has something to say.
- Justin I watched three episodes
of Game of Thrones without you--
- [Justin] Oh my gosh.
- OK.
And I'm sorry.
- Oh my God.
Quinta.
How could you?
(sobbing) I can't believe she
would do something like this
to me, I feel so betrayed (sobbing).
(sniffling)
I trusted her with my HBO GO password.
I guess
there's only one choice.
Zach,
will you
accept this key?
- (sobbing) Oh my God.
Yes.
Yes (sobbing).
This is the greatest day of my life, I
get the roommate of my dreams.
- Zach,
he's the one. I know it.
- Yes, tomorrow at five,
is that good for you?
Oh sorry, hold on one second.
I knew this was gonna happen and honestly,
I could care less.
I've set up three meetings
with three future tomorrow, so,
it's all good.
- Hey, uh,
you know
we have to share a bathroom
at the new place, right?
- Wait, what?
- I'm sorry.
I shoulda told you.
- No.
(upbeat music)
(acoustic guitar melody)
♫ Justin won't you be my roommate ♫
♫ Zach I will be your roommate ♫